you did an interview recently that  caught my eye because check this out  everybody oh yeah yeah  that sunflower jumpsuit what's happening  and where do i get one well i'm i'm  going to text you all the details but i  did learn that sunflowers and clearly  you have some there are your favorite  flower and here's the thing i'm so  bummed kelly because  you know we can't be doing this in  person we have to be doing this over  zoom but that didn't stop me  from getting you flowers that i could  give you virtually  i will i will just take them home for  myself but they're for you  so it's a gift for everyone yep i'm  still here  just waiting for you to subscribe if you  don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever